okay let me ask you a weird question we
talked about
craig wright a little bit but
a lot of people write to me one of two
emails
one email uh is uh
calling any coin outside of bitcoin a
uh a scam and then the other email
is saying my my favorite coin is
the best coin it's going to save the
world whatever that coin is
uh and so i sit back and i look at i
have no idea i
i trust i try to figure out like the
humans
that i trust in this space just but
basic human qualities but
do you think some coins are scams uh
do you think some coins maybe another
way to ask it are scammier than other
coins
how are people there looking outside of
the space where there's
all of these cryptocurrencies supposed
to figure out
what is a scam and not or how to use the
right kind of language when talking
about them
because there's the harshness of the
language from the bitcoin maximalist
that
doesn't just say everything is a scam
including ethereum
uh but they use terms like [ __ ] coin
that says it's not only a scam it's like
a waste of time i mean
every word you can use they say that
that's very harsh
and then some people are just apply the
word scam
a lot much much more conservatively and
just
refer to coins that legitimately are
trying to scam
people out of their money as scams so
what do we do with this word scam should
it ever be applied to coins
and uh is it a a binary thing or is it a
gray area
hmm it's i think it's definitely a gray
area like there's definitely
things that are really in actual scams
like i mean bit connects would be one
example of uh something that's away on
the scam
spectrum did you see their 2017
promotional video by the way
connect yeah hey what's up what's up
what's up
bitconnect this is it was this three
minute 48 second video that was just of
this guy
making this totally crazy rant and it
was at some
conference in vietnam where they were of
course like trying to
convince a whole bunch of people to buy
this coin and they had this claims about
how it would go to go up in value
yeah that was definitely like the peak
of these pure
completely scammy coins and you know
that was definitely really terrible and
i actually i feel like we have less
despite cryptocurrency as a whole being
bigger we actually have
quite a bit less of that now but then of
course you know there's this bit this
spectrum
of things that are not completely scams
um and then things that are
not scams and that are technically
totally fine projects but where
the their community is just incredibly
sketchy
and then all the way to you know things
that are where the community is nice but
maybe the
project is just fundamentally incapable
of achieving what it's trying to do or
in the community doesn't realize and
then
you know really good projects right so
like
if you want to go a step like
well if that's 100 scam then like you
know what would i call like say 80
scam well like bitcoin sv is one example
this is a craig wright's fork of bitcoin
like theoretically it's a blockchain
right it's a fork of bitcoin
it has some you know five hundred twenty
twelve megabyte blocks
if you really wanted to you could use
the blockchain you know it's uh
it satisfies the properties that you
know you can send transactions onto it
you can probably
um you know use it as as a backup to
store your files if you really wanted to
just because it has it has so much space
you know it might fail
but like it's
the but at the same time like you know
as they basically said
like craig wright is a scammer and like
half the
you know community is just totally that
[ __ ] insane so the humans
the humans of a particular
cryptocurrency is what makes for a scam
and not like the humans at the top that
have a voice
right guiding the community yeah like i
think you know in the case of bsv like
the humans they yeah
make just completely wrong and just
obviously
wrong claims about like what vsv is
capable of accomplishing and
look what it concealed we could
accomplish and like there's just
a lot of aspects of it that make it feel
like a money grab
so that's one example and then you know
you gotta go a bit
further and then you know you have like
the trons of the world
and like you know that's a platform you
know you can use it you can do
you can do stuff on it but at the same
time like you know
they did plagiarize the ipfs white paper
and then
you know they so they're scammy
qualities yeah see the thing that throws
me off a lot this makes it very
difficult for me
is that most coins but the ones that
make me feel like are
scammy have a large community of people
that are super positive about it
like and they'll write to me
now that said sort of on the flip side
of that
bitcoin people are also very positive
there's some sense and the the reason i
was
having like squinty eyes looking at
bitcoin
for quite a while is like why is
everyone so positive
i was getting total cult vibes
like like the ideas are not grounded in
truth but are grounded in an obsession
of like when you can artificially
conjure up a truth which is why i was a
little bit like worried about bitcoin
i think i've learned a lot since then to
where like
um i i learned to separate the community
from the ideas
and i think bitcoin is a revolutionary
idea on on many fronts
but still a community that's like
dogmatically excited about something
whatever that is makes me skeptical
maybe it's just like my upbringing
but when everybody's really excited
about something
it makes me um it makes me skeptical
and it make but it also makes me
difficult to decide what is this camera
or not because some of the most exciting
ideas in this world
have a community of people who are
excited about it right because it's um
i don't know i think space exploration
is super exciting and
uh and there's people i know a lot of
them that are
exceptionally excited about space
exploration
does that mean it's a scam no no uh so i
don't know what to do with that and so
most i just try to stay away i suppose
but it's
it's unfortunate because i'm sure
there's a lot of exciting technologies
in that space i mean like in the case of
bitcoin like i would definitely not call
bitcoin a scam
right again right i would not i would
i would also not call litecoin a scam
there's people who call litecoin a scam
because they just like say oh look you
know
it has no fundamental use case and the
concept of being silver to bitcoin's
goal
bitcoins gold is just like stupid and
you know it's a bit like
millie bitcoin is the silver to
bitcoin's gold um but
the at the same time like if you have
these people who just
you know they do seem to honestly
believe this and
uh like they are trying to just like
make like one be a litecoin as
best as they can then like that's to me
that's enough for it to not be a scam
yeah um
and then so yeah i think the the biggest
gray area is definitely between
like projects that
are earnest and but you know they have
just all sorts of these
like different combinations of flawed
qualities to them yeah
yeah i mean the the ones that
legitimately is a scam is when
the key people that are at the head of
the project are intentionally lying
and um i think as long as their the
intent
is to try to do good in the world even
if the
your actual implementation of that is
flawed i think that's not a scam
it could be full out ideas it could be
wrong ideas but it's not a scam
i'm learning to navigate this space yeah
it's it's definitely a very
challenging space to navigate i mean you
know it's uh
in some ways a reflection of the world
at large
yeah and as we've said maybe offline
that
the fact that money is involved makes it
a little bit more complicated
that um you know lives can be ruined
by um by by the choice of technologies
that are taking on so
it makes it more real more painful more
like elevated
the impact of this like imagine like mac
versus pc
wars if everyone who bought a macbook
had 10
apple shares inside of it and everyone
who had a pc had 10 microsoft shares
inside of it
and then you had you know the the elites
who bought
their macs back in 1983 and that they
spent 500. dead and now they have 40
million dollars and they
just think that they're these gurus who
understands the future of finance and
geopolitics and
they make theories about why you know
apple is the one that's going to bring
freedom to the world
and uh window is like you know secretly
allied with the access of evil
oh that's brilliant so yes this is so
brilliant so i think the right way to
think about this is we map
the some of the cryptocurrency battles
into the space of like emacs versus vim
or apple versus pc if
there was some stock that came along
with each each implementation of the you
know uh
each pc each mac that's fascinating this
is 100 correct
100 correct because then that really
energizes the armies of people debating
over this in a way that
something without money does not
you